oh i'm playing level c
i played left will see the other day i
played my immortal game against lawful c
the immortal i castled queenside with
checkmate against level c the other day
let's repeat the same opening
let's see if level c has learned
a lesson
oh no my pond
yeah we we did go into this uh kind of
funny gambit the other day
oh okay deviating from
[Music]
the previous game i'm still gonna play
in like a crazy
reckless insane style uh
g5 g5 suits that style
g5 on move four insisting on
the gambit
i'm just trying to remove the knight and
win
quickly
so
[Music]
yeah let's play this
whoa it's oxford typo thanks axe for
typo
with a raid shout out to typo who i
collabed with
the other day we did a nice kind of
chess
scrabble match
it was it was at least five hours long i
hope you're you're recovered hope you
had a nice stream
42 yeah 42 the meaning of life
oh we have the josh command too everyone
should wish
josh a happy belated birthday
e4 so if you're just joining i'm playing
i'm playing the froms gambit but kind of
crazy
and i don't know entirely what's
happening
[Music]
but it looks fun oh there's a funny line
queen e5
so white can't block on e2
[Music]
basically has to develop the king either
here or here
and then then we're gonna have some more
fun
if um am i meeting by force
okay not if wait a minute
okay if white blocks on e2 i win
material
but if king f2
i think it's force mate there
king d2 also looks fun yada yada
yeah it's a it's a serious pickle fairy
white
has to choose i mean there's what five
legal moves one two
three four five has to choose between
all the evils
what does bond cloud mean
i wish i could go back to the time where
i didn't know what bond cloud meant
like several years ago
okay so this isn't quite force mate but
it's close
so bishop c5 depending what white does
next it might be force mate
and white has three legal moves
oh wait a minute maybe it's not force
mate
i was fantasizing too much
i was thinking king f3 queen here king
here and then
mate but there's some bishop f4 move
and we'll see what happens
i think my first game against lawful see
i won in 11 moves
so i'm going to try and it might be hard
to
to beat that
also thank you flauds subbing for 23
months
okay so king is getting some fresh air
yeah bishop f4
best move so i'll just calmly develop
so level c has survived longer than the
first time we played
we reached move 11 and it hasn't uh
hasn't ended in mate
uh i don't think we're going to see a
queenside castle mate either
that's nice i have a small lead in
development
white's a bit underdeveloped
yeah queen h5 queen h5 would have looked
attractive but there's g4 there
though maybe i should have gone for it
queen h5 g4 there was queen
and d5 but
i have other ideas with knight not f6
uh mainly queen g4
yeah having lots of fun
so d4 i'm a little bit disappointed i
was fighting maiden one
this would have been a stylish mate but
uh okay life goes on
oh there's a funny line okay so it takes
wait a minute oh it's kind of tricky
actually
if i take there's bishop b5 so i should
play knight here
first
there's a really funny line there's a
line where i could i could potentially
queensly castle with mate
if king here i take takes
ah i was holding for 96 and then never
mind
okay it's still fun though king is being
chased around
uh how to do this
check i feel like i'm playing with my
food again
[Music]
oh i see it check oh no my bishop
check
you know you want to you know you want
to
come on oh check
i'm so disappointed i'm so disappointed
jack i'm still going to make it happen
though hopefully
can i not give more time
i can't give more time
uh
this is almost forcing it come on please
no
i'm not going to make you
on c4 how do i do this
this move or this move
oh i have a i have a different idea
okay so oh no my knight if here i castle
queen's light with mate please don't
flag
don't flag
upon searching for legal move
there we go
that's the second game in a row
against luffle c i don't think left will
see
level c was trying not to get mated
like this but it still worked
okay it's so satisfying
yeah hoppity-hoppity-hop i still have
this um
the top of the extension hoppity
hoppity-hoppity hoppity-hop
there we go okay youtube say hi to
twitchat
thank you numeroid just ending sad
oh yeah but sometimes you have to
experience sagginess before you can
experience happiness
what if he takes a night oh good
question what if he takes a night
if he takes a knight knight a6 check
oh let's let's turn this off for a
moment
so i was calculating uh king takes
queen e6 king digs b7 queen g7 oh no my
rook
and then kingside castle with checkmate
so depending which
line white chose there is potential for
kingside or queensland castle with meat